because we had to tell our employees
that we're going to start growing really
really really fast in an uncomfortable
way fast so imagine a 100 person company
starting to recruit about 20 people a
week into that into that group so within
less than a year we grew to over 400
people
and that was painful but it was really
necessary overnight we turned the
company from an r d company to a company
that can do manufacturing supply chain
have a full commercial entity and all
the other functions you need in a fully
functional company so we probably
squeezed three four years worth of
growth into 12 months period that was
painful but it was also very gratifying
to see
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to minute leaders today we're
going to be talking to somebody who's
literally changing lives of millions of
people meet adam de la zerda the ceo of
visby medical formerly click diagnostics
which he founded in 2012 to develop easy
use diagnostic tests in march of 2020
the company pivoted from work on a
sexual health test to tackle the
coronavirus and in july received fda
emergency authorization approval for its
portable covet 19 test he is also an
associate professor
in the department of structural biology
and electrical engineering at stanford
university school of medicine with
research interests spanning a broad
field of molecular imaging his lab is
developing new optical imaging tools
with applications to cancer and
ophthalmic diseases such as age-related
macular degeneration
adam delazerta welcome to 20 minute
leaders i'm so honored and excited to
have you here thank you for joining me
thanks so much for having me hey you
know i've been following visby medical
as a fan uh you know as part of the j
ventures community which is one of the
investors in invisible medical and there
are a few companies that i can truly you
know wake up and say wow i'm so excited
to be part of the impact they're making
and you know the work that you've been
doing with stanford from an academic
level and then transitioning into
visibility medical as an entrepreneur
and helping people
you know the way that they interface
with with the diagnostics of sexual
transit diseases and then pivoting and
making another product that's relevant
for kobet and we'll talk about that now
but your grander vision of empowering
people to take ownership of their
diagnostics and knowing what's happening
i think it's just remarkable and so adam
you know take it away tell me a little
bit about your own background and
upbringing and while transitioning to
visby
so
i'm a scientist by training and uh you
know i grew up in israel i'm a physicist
computer scientist electric engineer by
training
and i came to stanford actually for to
do my phd in electrical engineering i'll
be very honest i did not realize that i
will fall in love with the world of
medicine the moment i landed at stanford
and
i have to admit also at the time i
didn't realize that the engineers have
something to contribute to the world of
medicine actually wow start taking mcats
thinking i'm gonna have to probably drop
out of the phd program going to go to
medical school and it wasn't until i met
a very special person who was the
chairman of the department of
radiologists and beer who
would basically expose me to the world
of medicine in a way that i i never
quite realized before i ended up staying
in the in the stanford community for a
very short period of time i went to
another university just across the bay
and then got back to stanford design as
a as an assistant professor in the
department of structural biology in the
medical school
but you know in academia we focus very
much on on converting good ideas into
papers it very much felt to me that we
really needed to take that one extra
step and start a company that can make a
physical product that will help people
and that's where visby medical really
came to be i started working with this
vc firm in palo alto as an entrepreneur
in residence
and and through through doing some work
with them over a period of about two
years or so we created an investment
hypothesis and then end up starting a
company that really was intended to
solve that problem that we started with
and that was about eight years ago we're
now a little over 400 people in the
company so we grew quite quickly but
it's been a lot of fun to actually see
an idea you come up with turning into a
physical product that actually helps
somebody in the field
is just incredibly gratifying feeling
about that
so
to connect the thoughts do you know
growing up in israel you know as an
engineer was did you know that at some
point you're going to be building your
own company and sort of your entrance
into the medical world was that
something in between but you always knew
that it was going to connect somewhere
or or
how did it come about
actually not at all i
the reason why i went to stanford is
because stanford has one of the best
groups of quantum computers and at the
time now 16 years ago i was my mind was
set on on going into the world of
quantum computers i i got to stanford
and and
that's actually somewhat of a sad case
where a good friend of mine just passed
away from brain cancer and for me that
changed that changed what i wanted to do
in life it was very clear to me that if
there's any way i can contribute somehow
to the world of medicine i really should
and by the way that centralized theme
was
was relevant then and still relevant
today many times in the world of
medicine we treat patients in the blind
when we make decisions on treatment we
don't really know what we're dealing
with
we give drugs when we don't really know
if they're going to be effective or not
same for chemotherapy same for
infectious diseases how many times did
you go to the doctor got some treatment
and the doctor to call you a few days
later saying hey the result just came
back from the lab turns out they gave
you the wrong treatment should it give
you a different antibiotic or i
shouldn't have given an antibiotic at
all you have a virus not a bacterial
infection
right now so you're visbe medical is
starting with sexually transmitted
diseases right and you're looking at the
space of how do we help people and
empower people to take ownership over
this exact problem of the diagnosis well
what is sort of the thesis that you came
up with while an entrepreneur in
residence that that sort of led to this
first product for visby medical
so the first question we asked herself
is why is it that in the world of
infections and very uniquely in the
world of infections
do we treat patients before we know what
the diagnosis is because it's very
unique to that area of medicine nowhere
else in medicine is that acceptable
right you will never see
a physician telling a patient look i'm
not sure if you have cancer or not let's
give you some chemotherapy and see how
it's doing right it's it's inconceivable
to see that same thing for heart
diseases you're not going to open up
some patient and do an open heart
surgery unless you know for sure that
patient has a heart disease and for
infections that's exactly what we're
doing we treat them first and only a few
days later the result comes back from
the lab and the reason for that is not
because of lack of technology there is a
technology and it works really well for
diagnosing infections it's called pcr
we've all been tested multiple times
over this past year and a half or so for
pcr recovery but but pcr can test any
infection in the body you pick the
sample from whatever area that hurts you
send it to the lab they'll tell you what
it is
the fundamental challenge is really that
of
patient accessibility
is the technology accessible to anyone
anywhere anytime the the answer today at
least is no
just take sexually transmitted
infections just a few basic infections
like chlamydia gonorrhea kimonos in the
united states are almost 50 million
tests like this every year and all of
them are run in the centralized lab now
close your eyes for a moment and ask
yourself five ten years from now well
those 50 million tests will still be run
in the lab
i can tell that my answer is i surely
hope the answer is no exactly if that's
still the case will be really bad do you
know how many times the result that the
lab is generating doesn't make it back
to the patient
it's about 50 percent of the time
so we have all these tens of millions of
tests being run every year with positive
results that make it back to the doctor
the doctor try to call back on the
patient but the patient is not picking
up the patient is long gone maybe the
patient did not even give the right
phone number
we have that all the time and because of
that we have patients are now suffering
the long-term consequences of these stds
infertility pelvic inflammation there's
list goes on and on ectopic pregnancy
life-threatening conditions because of
an untreated std and it's not because
lack of diagnosis it's lack of patient
access when we actually needed to know
what the result was it wasn't available
to us
so that was the insight we said we have
to solve that not about coming up with
new technology it's about creating and
solving a patient access problem
and i'll add on top of that you know i'm
sure that the consumer behavior that
there's there's a lot of friction to
getting these tests and i'm sure that
there's countless cases you know besides
those 50 million tests are being
administered i'm sure there's millions
of cases of people that would like to
get tested but there's so much friction
to go and get those tests and to wait
those long hours and
and you know go through that complicated
process that you know by making it
accessible you're actually you know we
don't we don't know you know the
question of recall and precision we
don't know what we're missing of the
people that didn't get tested for this
i think it's fascinating what happened
you know a year and a half ago two years
ago covet is breaking out stanford
stanford's campus is shutting down i was
evicted from campus overnight
where where are you at where's your your
head at you're involved in the pcr space
so we
so in march of 2020 we just submitted
the package to the fda for our sexually
transmitted infection test we just
finished the clinical trial it took us
over a year just to run the trial and
many years prior to that to develop the
technology
and there we are in march of 2020
submitting a package to the fda and of
course as you can imagine
fda had other priorities at that point
in time
it was very clear for us that the
fundamental technology we created for
for infectious diseases for stds and
other types of infections can also be
relevant for covid and so we actually
did an all hands meeting we were about
100 people in the company at the time
and we were very open with our employees
and said
we're
we're seriously thinking about joining
the fight against kofi we think it's the
right thing to do we think there's also
potential real benefits for the company
because it's an opportunity for us to
showcase to the world what you can do by
taking a big large sofa size million
dollar instrument and miniaturize it to
something the size of your phone
and then we said if you can actually do
that
and you can apply that for covid
what would that mean for the pandemic
because it's very clear this is not
going anywhere
so
i'll just show you that was actually
pretty hard discussion because we had to
tell our employees that we're going to
start growing really really really fast
in an uncomfortable way fast so imagine
a 100 person company starting to recruit
about 20 people a week into that into
that group so within less than a year we
grew to over 400 people
and that was painful but it was really
necessary overnight we turned the
company from an r d company to a company
that can do manufacturing supply chain
have a full commercial entity and all
the other functions you need in a fully
functional company so we probably
squeezed three four years worth of
growth into 12 months period this was
painful but it was also very gratifying
to see
to see actual patients using in this
case our covi test and and in less than
six months we've gone from deciding we
want to do a cov test
to pivoting and adapting our technology
to build really the first single use
rapid pcr test ever created for covid
and to getting through all the way
through clinical trials bidding to the
fda and to the fda's credit they've been
moving incredibly fast because they
really prioritize covid so we were able
by the the fourth quarter of last year
to already launch that really important
product out to the market
unbelievable what is that experience
like for you as a ceo as an entrepreneur
as an academic as an engineer you're on
boarding 20 people a week to the company
that you've built with your own hands
i can
only imagine how many hours of sleep you
had that you know this past year
what is that experience like for you on
a personal level
well
it was definitely challenging times
actually we just had our third baby also
in march of 2020.
so a lot of things happened at the same
time for us and of course managing
managing that and managing the company
and and really making sure that the the
fundamentals of the company that we
really love and cherish which is
primarily our culture our values
can still can still flourish and get
maintained there and that's not an
obvious thing
imagine you if you left for a month just
on a family leave or something in your
back the company just doubled in size
and
and that's really really dangerous if
you don't if you're not being really
intentional about what kind of
atmosphere what kind of people you bring
and we've made some mistakes admittedly
along the way but time was really of the
essence there's so many stories to tell
you from
as you know supply chain was so heavily
disrupted over this past year
from a simple double-sided tape that we
couldn't get on time that shut down our
manufacturing line to how do we prevent
our own employees from getting covered
you see i mean our headquarters here
we're all getting tested for kovid all
the time but it's really challenging to
do it in a way that can keep the
manufacturing line safe that allows you
to continue to scale quickly
reinvent yourself it's been a really
interesting challenging thrilling
exciting year i can see so many
adjectives about this past year and a
half
is there a sense of
you know mission
or urgency because you're dealing in a
state of uncertainty
you know right now you know we're seeing
the headlines of another surge in europe
we have no we don't as much as we want
to speculate and draw statistical models
we really don't know where things are
going to head and what variants are
going to arise and so in your building a
company and you're doubling you know
pretty much over a month and your
employees are working on a product that
is relevant yesterday and you know you
have to get out of there what is sort of
the sense in the office like
the
the sense of urgency and the sense of
purpose
was
amazing
not to say that before the pandemic it
wasn't there obviously
the people here
joined the company not because that's an
opportunity to make you know to to
increase their salary by meaningful
amount of it where i think we're
we're obviously treating our employees
very well but but there's another reason
why people are here beyond just
financial gains it's really because they
feel like they can make a meaningful
impact on patients lives and they're
really excited by that
but when the
when the pandemic hit
that sense of purpose just increased so
much because it got so close to home it
affected all of us
and we all felt both if this product
existed in large volumes it would have
meaningfully changed our lives so with
our investors calling us trying to help
obviously our board of directors
everyone in the ecosystem around this
company was helpful the federal
government stepped in in amazing massive
massive way and was incredibly helpful
to us not just financially giving us
many many grants tens of millions of
dollars to accelerate our vision and
push it forward as fast as we can
but in addition that even dedicating
people in the federal government to help
us
get better chances with suppliers to
make sure that we get the supplies that
we need in order to produce those coffee
tests it was just just an immense
immense
platform that that took really to create
the work of so many people both within
the company and outside the company and
every single one of them worked with an
extreme sense of purpose it was it was
very heartening it was very difficult
but very heartening here i have to say
incredible if if i'm taking you a few
years down the line
and you know we're seeing a world in
which i can go to
to different pharmacies and i can and i
can purchase these different devices and
empower myself you know and everybody
around me to take ownership of this
knowledge and and the diagnostics
are is there going to be consumer
behavior that needs to be shifted or any
education for the market that you think
we need to do or is this a trivial thing
that people are just waiting for and as
soon as we have this device people are
going to feel comfortable using it how
do you see sort of the scale out of the
product
i think it's important for us to
leverage as much as possible at least
existing ecosystems that work well
and to the extent that we can help fill
in important gaps it's certainly a much
easier path so you don't go through an
uphill battle here
fundamentally changing consumer behavior
is hard but the pandemic showed that
there is a way to change using behavior
so here are two examples
take the telemedicine services
telemedicine existed before the pandemic
but after the pandemic immediately when
epidemic start it increased by 50 fold
not 50 50 fold
and by the way it's not coming down it's
staying high because people realized if
i can speak to my doctor over the phone
or over in
a video chat i'd much rather do that
than going to the actual clinic
that's one really meaningful ecosystem
that developed almost overnight
here's another one last mile delivery
services yeah also the door dashes the
ubers of the world right didn't they
existed before but oh boy oh boy that's
my delivery system
really really you know stepped up to the
task over the during the pandemic so
think about these two ecosystems and
what you can now enable from a user
journey point of view if you just add to
that a visby device like this you can
actually bring the accuracy of a
laboratory test to somebody's home
it means that as a patient imagine that
journey where you can allow somebody
from their
from the
privacy and convenience of their own
home to go there tell the medicine app
and say this is the symptoms i'm feeling
that is now generating the prescription
so your insurance will hopefully pay for
that so you only have to pay maybe a
small copay
a door dasher comes knocking on your
door or somebody are just
giving you this device you run the test
and within within really minutes you now
know what you have
and then an hour later
prescription comes to your door and
giving you the actual drug that you can
now take you can actually allow people
to go from being bored about something
having symptoms to a definitive
diagnosis to a pill going into their
mouth and that entire journey takes a
couple of hours and they never have to
leave home for that instead of days or
weeks
so i think that's a journey we're trying
to enable
and to your question i think the right
way to get there is by leveraging the
existing ecosystems that really grew up
over the last year and a half so well
incredible
academia
high tech
you know research deep technology you
know
software obviously is fundamentally
changing the way that we that we live
you know the integration of software and
hardware with what you're doing is
changing the way that we interact with
the world around us and obviously some
of the most interesting uh interesting
technologies are being developed in
academia like like like where you're you
were at and so what you know what needs
to happen in your eyes in order to
mitigate some of the dissonance or some
of the tension that we might have today
so that we we have you know papers are
great but we also have these deep
technology advancements actually coming
into play in our daily lives and
empowering you know humanity to be
propelled forward
of course no i mean
many universities have already figured
out
how to how to enable
really deep meaningful partnerships
between academia and and industry i
think stanford is really a wonderful
example for that
in the medical school so many times
we're partnering with with industry but
but always maintaining a very
very high level of academic freedom and
and that's really critical so for
example when we when we launch this test
now for sexually transmitted infections
the reason why we're able to launch that
is because we ran proper clinical trials
which means that we actually went out to
15 different sites across the united
states and we ask them those leading
academical medical centers to
to run that clinical trial for us in
order to keep the academic freedom now
to keep the
the transparency that you need in the
clinical study
we really needed to have that really
deep collaboration
and and i think generally
industry
should be incredibly incredibly grateful
for the fact that we have such leading
academic centers around this country
that can really partner with them like
this same thing now also with software
and the importance of ai also in the
world of medicine we're very much going
to be relying on those kind of
capabilities and it's those those new
ideas it's it's those it's that student
in a you know in a cs laboratory that's
thinking what would be a really exciting
project for me to work on now that's
doing things that that in industry
perhaps would be considered too high of
a risk maybe not worth exploring right
now
that that academic freedom that that
student has
is is something that's fundamentally
important and we never want to disrupt
that academic freedom but we certainly
want to expose it more and more to
industry so that we can make more more
meaningful ties
incredible adam i want to thank you so
much not for just the episode and but
but for everything that you're doing for
the incredible impact that you're making
and for the adaptability i think it's so
inspiring to think that you've been
working on this company i believe it was
six years up to the point where covet
hit right and then overnight making this
difficult decision you know what we're
going to we're going to take what we've
done and we're going to accelerate the
growth now to be able to meet the needs
of the world and find a win-win
situation with the government with
humanity with with the company and and
continue to to lead strongly and still
be so optimistic about it
and and again i can only imagine what
that year must have been like for you
and as you know as a future entrepreneur
i can only wish for myself to to have
the privilege of going through through
such an incredible and monumental
experiences you've had and i'm sure it's
a story you'll be telling for many many
many years and so adam thank you for
everything i can't wait to have these
devices all around us and for humanity
to enjoy the fruits of your of your work
and thank you for everything thank you
for the inspiration
that's very kind of you to say thank you
so much for having me take care bye-bye
thank you